[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd with a long awaited
tutorial and the first of 2010
with a fresh start to the new year today
i'm going to be showing you guys how to
get a screensaver i showed off a bit in
a good portion of my late 2009 videos
it's called the kelly's matrix
screensaver hopefully it looks familiar
to you it's one of the more popular
screen savers in the tech community you
might have seen me or chris pirillo or a
number of other youtubers rocking this
one today i'll be showing you not only
how to get it but i'll be giving you a
full walkthrough of the feature set of
this program so if you're interested
stay tuned we've got a lot to cover here
we go
[Music]
so to make finding this as quick and
easy as possible you can find the screen
saver by visiting any major search
engine maybe google and typing in matrix
screen saver with an x it'll be the
first link this will take you to the
kelly software website the hub of all
things centered around the screen saver
and to get and download the installer
scroll about halfway down past all the
information on the page until you find
your os versions installer the
installation process is surprisingly
really really simple it'll install
everything into your registry go ahead
and give you all the options for the
screen saver without you doing a thing
so this is what it's going to look like
once you've finished downloading that
screen saver
once you've run through the installer
all you have to do is get to your screen
savers menu somewhere in whatever
operating system you're using and you
should find the matrix screen saver
waiting for you there from here i'm just
going to show you guys all the options
and things that you can do with this
screen saver so across the top you can
obviously see all the awesome things
that you can do with the screen saver
you know you can change the color you
can have it uh create a little logo with
the matrix effect now i haven't actually
used all these features in the
background of my videos but i do plan on
doing that more often i guess uh to you
know get attention uh but you know it
does look really cool um adding in i
guess a logo if you have a red logo and
the red effect on the screen saver it
does look really good
so once you guys have finished around
with playing uh playing around with the
settings in the screen saver go ahead
and hit save changes and it'll save
everything you've made changes to in the
screen saver program and once you've
saved that you can go back to the
windows manager hit apply and hit ok and
you should be all good with that
so that is basically it for the matrix
screen saver i hope you guys enjoyed
this hd tutorial and there will be a lot
more where that came from a lot of
tutorials coming up and i'll definitely
be showing you guys as much as i can in
the tech world in hd so thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys later
peace